n avons le plaisir monsieur le ministre
de vous accueillir aujourd'hui pour vous
entendre sur le projet de loi
constitutionnel relatif à la liberté de
recourir à l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse après son adoption par le
conseil des ministres le 12 décembre
2023 la commission des lois a déjà eu
l'occasion à plusieurs reprises
d'exprimer son attachement à la cons
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG je
rappelle que dans le contexte de
l'émotion suscitée par l'arrêt de la
Cour suprême des États-Unis du 24 juin
2022 de nombreuses initiatives
parlementaires ont été prises à ce sujet
et ont déjà été adopté parce que notre
commission a adopté le 9 novembre 2022
la proposition constitutionnelle de
Madame berger visant à garantir le droit
à l'interruption volonire de grossesse
et le 16 novembre suivant nous avons
fait de même avec la proposition de
Madame Panau visant à protéger et à
garantir le droit fondamentale à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
et à la contraception l'Assemblée a
adopté par suite ces deux propositions
dans l'un ordre différent le 24 novembre
2022 pour celle de Madame Panau après
retraite de celle de Madame berger et
qui a été malheureusement largement
écrite par le Sénat le 1er février 2023
et c'est la raison pour laquelle avec un
débat qui a largement eu lieu qui a
permis au gouvernement de pouvoir
s'appuyer sur le travail des
parlementaires que vous avez pu avancer
sur le plan sémantique avec un débat euh
juridique entre droits et liberté qui
sont garantis à la femme d'avorter et
encore sur le positionnement dans la
constitution de cette
constitutionnalisation c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous vous accueillons
aujourd'hui Monsieur le gardessau avec
le projet loi de l'exécutif qui a repris
l'initiative sur ce sujet est ce qui
permet d'ouvrir la voix à un congrès
dans le cadre de l'article 89 qui semble
à toutes et tous la plus adaptée à cette
révision constitutionnelle monsieur le
gardess vous allez avoir la parole pour
nous présenter votre projet de loi je
donnerai la parole ensuite au au
rapporteur et comme l'usage le veut les
orateurs des groupes pouront ensuite 4
minutes pour s'exprimer vous avez la
parole monsieur le président de la
commission des lois monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
députés permettez-moi tout
d'abord de vous présenter de manière
républicaine toutv de bonne et heureuse
année
nouvell je suis très heureux d'être
parmi vous ce
soir alors que la Commission examine le
projet de loi
constitutionnel relatif à la liberté de
recourir à l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse que j'ai l'honneur et la
fierté de porter devant le
Parlement je le dis d'emblé ce projet de
loi constitutionnel dont nous mesurons
toutes et tous l'importance et
l'aboutissement de nombreuses
initiatives parlementaires et de débats
déjà
approfondis lors du 2è semestre 2022
propositions de loi
constitutionnelleyant pour objet
d'inscrire le droit de recourir à l'IVG
dans la Constitution ont ainsi été
déposé devant l'une ou l'autre des deux
assemblées je souhaite rendre hommage à
ces initiatives qui auront toutes j'en
suis convaincu
utilement contribuer à la réflexion
commune autour de ce projet je veux
saluer en particulier l'initiative de
l'ancienne présidente Aurore berger et
de la présidente
panneau qui ont permis que l'assemblée
soit moteur de ce projet de révision
constitutionnel le projet du
gouvernement fait suite à ses travaux et
à l'appel qui lui a été lancé et auquel
le président de la République a répondu
favorablement c'est en effet le 8 mars
2023 à l'occasion de son discours
prononcé en hommage à Gisel alimic le le
président a appelé je je le cite à
changer notre Constitution afin d'y
graver la liberté des femmes de recourir
à l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
pour assurer
solennellement que rien ne pourra
entraver ou défaire ce qui sera ainsi
irréversible ce projet de loi
constitutionnel entend donc dans le
présent prolongement des intentions des
proposition de loi présidente précédente
pardon et comme s était engagé le
président de la République soumettre au
Parlement une rélection
d'équilibre parmi celles qui ont été
respectivement voté par
l'Assemblée et par le Sénat ce projet de
loi
constitutionnel vise à créer le
consensus entre les deux
assemblées à partir de constat et
d'objectifs
partagés le constat tout d'abord a pu
donner lieu à des divergences
d'appréciation mais il me semble
désormais
clair comme le Conseil d'État l'a
souligné dans son avis d'une très grande
qualité il n'existe pas aujourd'hui de
véritaable protection
supralégislative du droit ou de la
liberté de recourir à
l'IVG la Convention européenne des
droits de l'homme ne comporte pas de
disposition spécifiques sur la
avortement par ailleurs la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme
considère que le droit au respect de la
vie privée et familiale protégé par
l'article 8 de la Convention ne
peut-être regardé comme consacrante un
droit à l'avortement
elle renvoie par conséquent à la marge
d'appréciation de chaque État dans la
recherche d'équilibre
entre le droit à la vie privée de la
mère et la protection de l'enfant à
naître de la même manière la Cour de
justice de l'Union européenne se borne à
rappeler en l'absence de dispositions
spécifiques sur ce point la compétence
des États-membres et renvoie à
l'appréciation du législateur
national quant au Conseil
constitutionnel il a jugé conforme à la
Constitution les différentes lois
relatives à l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse se
il a examiné l'équilibre ménager entre
d'une part la sauvegarde de la dignité
de la personne humain Maine contre toute
forme de dégradation et et d'autre part
la liberté de la femme qui découle de
l'article 2 de la Déclaration de
1789 le Conseil constitutionnel n'est
pas allé plus loin il a même pris le
soin de souligner au sujet de
l'IVG qu'il il ne dispose pas d'un
pouvoir général d'appréciation et de
décision de même nature que celui du
Parlement et qu'il ne lui appartient
donc pas de remettre en cause au regard
de l'état des connaissances et des
techniques les disposition prise par le
législateur ainsi vous le voyez la
liberté des femmes de recourir à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
ne bénéficie pas à ce jour d'une
véritable
consécration
constitutionnelle l'objectif du
gouvernement est donc tout aussi clair
et il rejoint je crois les positions
déjà exprimées à l'Assemblée nationale
et au Sénat l'objectif de ce projet de
loi constitutionnel et d'accorder à
cette liberté une protection
constitutionnelle sans toutefois figer
la législation actuelle ni créer une
forme de droit
totalement absolu et sans limite cette
protection
constitutionnelle doit être suffisamment
souple pour permettre au législateur de
continuer son œuvre en la matière et
donc ménager un équilibre
satisfaisant notamment au regard des
évolutions techniques médicales
scientifiques qui pourrai
advevenir ce qu'il s'agit d'empêcher
c'est que le législateur puisse un jour
interdire tout recours
ivg ou même qu'il en restreigne si
drastiquement les conditions d'accès que
la substance même de la liberté d'y
recourir sen trou s'en trouverait alors
atteinte il y a vous le voyez un
équilibre à
trouver le gouvernement souhaite donc
consacrer pleinement la valeur
constitutionnelle de la liberté de la
femme de recourir à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse tout en
reconnaissant
le rôle du législateur d'organiser les
conditions d'exercice de cette liberté
de cette façon les deux objectifs semble
pouvoir être conciliés avec une
rédaction qui protège la liberté ainsi
reconnue tout en préservant le rôle
essentiel du
Parlement pour parvenir à cet objectif
le gouvernement a retenu une voie
médiane entre les rédactions de
l'Assemblée nationale et du Sénat le
projet de loi comporte une disposition
unique ayant pour objet de modifier
l'article 34 de la Constitution en y
ajoutant après le 17e alinéa un alinéa
ainsi
rédigé la loi détermine les conditions
dans lesquelles
s'exerce la liberté garantie à la femme
d'avoir recours à une interruption
volontaire de
grossesse le gouvernement a d'abord
retenu l'article 34 de la Constitution
comme l'avait fait le Sénat en terme
juridique cet emplacement paraît en
effet le plus adapté j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion d'indiquer et les diverses
versions voté par le Parlement en sont
la preuve aucun emplacement au sein de
la Constitution n'apparaît idéal mais le
choix de l'article 34 paraît préférable
à la création d'un article 66 6- 2 au
sein du titre relatif à l'autorité
judiciaire et consécutif à l'article
66-1 relatif à l'abolition de la peine
de mort il faut à ce titre rappeler que
la jurisprudence du Conseil
constitutionnelle reconnaît que
l'article 34 de la Constitution peut
contrairement à ce qu'une première
lecture pourrait sembler indiquer
accueillir des règles de fond et M
mettre des obligations positives à la
charge du législateur c'est par exemple
ce qui a été fait avec la révision
constitutionnelle du 23 juillet 2008 qui
a prévu à l'article 34 que la loi fixe
les règles concernant notamment la
liberté le pluralisme et l'indépendance
des médias le projet fait par ailleurs
le choix du mot liberté plutôt que du
mot
droit ce choix
je le sais a été au combien commenté
mais sa portée ne doit pas être
surestimée car ainsi que l'a relevé dans
son avis le conseil d'étint il n'existe
pas dans les textes ni dans la
jurisprudence du Conseil constitutionnel
de différence établies entre ces deux
termes si le gouvernement a choisi ce
terme c'est dans un souci de clarté il
ne s'agit pas de créer un droit absolu
et sans
limite mais de faire faire référence à
l'autonomie de la femme et de garantir
ainsi l'exercice d'une liberté qui lui
appartient dans les conditions prévues
par la loi enfin mesdames et messieurs
les députés le Gouvernement a souhaité
par la rédaction qu'il propose insister
sur le fait que si les conditions de
cette liberté sont déterminées par le
législateur cette liberté doit rester
dans tous les cas garantie aux femmes
qui en bénéficie c'est là un point
particulièrement important ce mot
garantie issu des travaux menés par
votre assemblée vise là aussi à exprimer
clairement l'intention poursuivie que
les choses soient bien claires il ne
s'agit pas d'une simple attribution de
compétence au législateur mais bien de
la création d'une obligation positive à
sa charge celle de protéger cette
liberté que la Constitution garantit
dans les conditions qu'il estime
approprié l'objectif est bien qu'aucune
majorité future ne puisse réellement
porter atteinte à cette liberté
intangible qui est celle pour la femme
de disposer de son corps un mot enfin si
vous le voulez bien sur les effets
attendus de cette révision Constitution
tout
d'abord c'est un point essentiel aucune
disposition législative en vigueur ne
devrait se voir remise en cause par
l'adoption de cette révision de la
Constitution le Conseil d'État l'a
lui-même très précisément constaté et
tel et bien l'intention du gouvernement
de manière claire et précise et pour
répondre par anticipation à certaines
craintes exprimées ici ou là la
consécration de cette liberté N porte
pas la remise en question d'une autre ou
d'autres liberté et notamment et
notamment pas la liberté de conscience
des médecins des
sages-femmes qui permet de choisir de ne
pas pratiquer d'interruption volontaire
de grossesse si cet acte est contraire à
leur conviction cette liberté là est
évidemment
préservé ensuite la rédaction proposée
entend bien rendre clair le fait que la
décision
d'avorter n'appartient qu'à la femme
enceinte et à elle seule
elle ne elle ne nécessite ni
l'autorisation d'un tiers que ce soit le
conjoint ou les parents ni
l'appréciation d'un autre personne cette
liberté est strictement personnelle
elle
est d'ailleurs reconnu à toute femme
enceinte et même à toutes personnees en
enceinte sans considération de son état
civil sans considération de son âge de
sa nationalité ou de la régularité de
son séjour en
France enfin j'y insiste cette rédaction
ne vise pas à créer une forme de droit
opposable le gouvernement n'ignore pas
les difficultés matérielles et concrètes
qui peuvent encore exister dans l'accès
à l'IVG et notamment sur certain une
partie du territoire il ne s'agit il
s'agit là d'un autre sujet qui n'est pas
d'ordre constitutionnel en effet nous
sommes réunis aujourd'hui pour réviser
notre Constitution pas pour voter je ne
sais quel mesure relevant du périmètre
du ministère de la Santé et qui ne
ménage pas ses efforts pour améliorer
l'accès à l'IVG partout sur le
territoire des annonces ont d'ailleurs
été faites pas plus plus tard qu'il y a
quelques instants au QAG cette révision
de la Constitution ne lèvera pas toutes
les difficultés mais elle prémunira les
femmes en France d'une éventuelle
régression brutale de leur liberté de
recourir à l'avortement c'est là la
volonté exprimée par l'Assemblée puis le
Sénat c'est là l'objectif du président
de la République poursuivi par le
gouvernement ce projet de révision
constitutionnelle mesdames et messieurs
les députés constitue le point
d'équilibre entre les nombreux travaux
engagés dans les deux chambres et
commencer d'ailleurs ici même parce
qu'elle respecte les priorités de
l'Assemblée parce qu'elle respecte le
travail du Sénat cette rédaction devrait
nous permettre j'en suis convaincu de
trouver une majorité dans les deux
chambres et ensuite d'obtenir une
majorité qualifiée au Congrès je forme
le vœ que nos débats suffiront à
dissiper les dernières hésitations et
permettront à notre pays par le vote de
ce cette loi constitutionnel de franchir
un pas historique pour les femmes de
notre pays la France deviendrait alors
le premier pays au monde à protéger
cette liberté inaliénable de la femme
dans sa
constitution merci monsieur le ministre
monsieur
rapporteur
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues merci
monsieur le ministre pour votre
présentation du projet de loi
constitutionnelle soumis au Parlement
par le gouvernement en tant que
rapporteur il me revient de dire qu'il
s'agit d'un texte fortement attendu par
le Parlement qui en avait pris
l'initiative dès le début de cette
législature mais également par nos
concitoyennes et nos concitoyens
les membres de la majorité
présidentielle des groupes de la France
insoumise socialiste écologiste de la
Gauche démocrate et républicaine en
avait pris l'initiative et on ne peut
que saluer le choix du président de la
République de remettre l'ouvrage sur le
métier pour permettre une adoption
rapide et autonome de cette révision
j'en formule le V le Parlement a
travaillé en bonne intelligence et nous
nous devons de poursuivre sur cette voie
pour mémoire en novembre 2022
l'assemblée national a adopté à une
large majorité
337 voix pour contre 32 une rédaction
fruit d'un consensus trans-partisan qui
reconnaissait la garantie du droit à
l'IVG et à un accès effectif à celui-ci
dans la foulée le Sénat qui avait
jusqu'àors fait valoir sa réticence à
l'inscription de l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse dans la
Constitution a également adopté une
rédaction certes moins ambitieuse mais
dont le sens était néanmoins clair et
historique les deux chambres souhaitent
faire aboutir une révision
constitutionnelle sur ce sujet c'est le
message qui était à leur envoyé que les
choses soi clair ici mes chers collègues
nous respectons l'opinion de ceux qui
s'interrogent sur l'opportunité
d'inscrire le droit à livivéger dans la
Constitution réformer notre Constitution
est un acte fort il est la volonté que
nous exprimons nous constituants
d'inscrire le choix du peuple présent
pour le peuple futur réformer notre
Constitution c'est au fond marquer le
présent pour protéger l'avenir pour la
suite de nos débats je crois qu'il faut
malgré tout circonscrire le périmètre de
nos discussions je veux le dire
clairement en préambule de nos
discussion ce que ce projet est et ce
qu'il n'est pas il ne s'agit pas
aujourd'hui de discuter du cadre
législatif en vigueur ni de préparer de
futures évolutions législatives visant à
élargir la liberté de recourir à l'IVG
en aucun cas nos débats seront scrutés
en cas de contentieux et les intentions
du Gouvernement et du Parlement doivent
être claires la rédaction soumise
n'implique nullement une évolution du
droit existant et ne saurait être source
d'un nouveau contentieux par exemple par
voie de question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité le Conseil d'État est
ton peu plus clair et précis sur ce
point en revanche le projet qui nous est
soumis remplit l'objectif que nous
partageons faire en sorte qu'il ne soit
pas possible de modifier la loi afin
d'interdire tout recours à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
ou d'en restreindre les conditions
d'exercice de telle façon qu'elle
priverait cette liberté de toute
l'adoption de ce texte nous paraît
indispensable pour renforcer la
protection juridique de cette liberté la
Constitution recessens déjà de nombreux
droits et libertés sans distinguer
d'ailleurs ces deux notions qui valent
l'une pour l'autre dans ces préambules
mais également dans ces articles laïcité
égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
interdiction de la peine de mort libre
administration des collectivités
territoriales droit d'asile et bien
d'autres il n'y a donc pas d'incohérence
ou de risque à reconnaître un nouveau
droit au contraire il est même de la
responsab AB ilité du législateur
constituant d'en prendre la
responsabilité sans attendre que le
Conseil constitutionnel reconnaisse ou
non ce nouveau droit de manière
prétorienne ne croyons pas non plus que
la protection de l'IVG par la loi est
suffisante pour nous prémunir contre
tout risque d'atteinte à cette liberté
certes le Conseil constitutionnel a
admis la conformité à la Constitution
des différentes réformes concernant
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
il a considéré que le législateur avait
toujours respecté l'équilibre entre la
liberté de la femme tel qu'elle découle
de l'article 2 de la Constitution et la
sauvegarde de la dignité de la personne
humaine contre toute forme de
dégradation notons cependant trois
limites à cette protection premièrement
s'il admet sa constitutionnalité le
Conseil n'a jamais reconnu l'IVG comme
un droit ou une liberté fondamentale en
soi comme il a pu le faire dans d'autres
cas la liberté d'enseignement par
exemple deièmement le Conseil n'a jamais
eu à se prononcer sur une restriction du
droit à l'IVG et on peut s'interroger
sur sa capacité à déclarer
inconstitutionnel de telles dispositions
sur le fondement de l'équilibre qu'il a
défini et qui repose sur une
interprétation déjà extensive de
l'article 2 de la Déclaration des Droits
de l'Homme et du Citoyen troisièmement
le Conseil reconnaît sur cette question
un large pouvoir d'appréciation au
législateur ce qui est bien normal
contte tenu du silence des textes
constitutionnels en la matière c'est
cette ambiguïté cette incertitude que
nous souhaitons lever sans priver le
juge constitutionnel de son office la
modification de l'article 34 envoie
explicitement la prérogative de du
législateur pour encadrer cette liberté
qui ne saurait être absolue l'ajout du
mot garantie principale évolution par
rapport à la rédaction du Sénat qui est
très largement reprise par ailleurs doit
renforcer la protection désormais de
rang constitutionnel de cette liberté
contre d'éventuelles atteintes à
l'avenir à l'inverse la suppression du
mot garanti je vous le dire rétablirait
une incertitude sur l'intention du
constituant voire même indiquerait que
celui-ci à contrario n'a pas souhaité
garantir ce droit ce qui serait
contreproductif c'est pourquoi nous
resterons impérativement attachés à ce
mot plus largement concernant l'ensemble
de la rédaction qui nous est proposée
par le projet de loi constitutionnelle
je vous le dis chers collègues je pense
qu'elle est la plus robuste et la plus
opportune sur le plan juridique au
regarde des auditions que j'ai mené de
l'avis du Conseil d'État avis
particulièrement positif concernant la
rédaction qui est proposée il est
important de le souligner et les travaux
de nos collègues sénateurs je défends la
position aujourd'hui que cette rédaction
est précise et ne crée aucune
ambivalence concernant l'objectif que
nous poursuivons l'emplacement retenu à
l'article 34 de la Constitution fait
sens au regard de notre histoire
constitutionnelle et de son évolution il
n'a aucunement pour conséquence de
donner moins de portée à la liberté
ainsi garantie cette rédaction est enfin
de nature à garantir une protection qui
respecte le choix individuel de chaque
personne qui souhaite recourir à une
interruption volontaire de grossesse je
pense par ailleurs que cette rédaction
est de nature à nous permettre de
trouver un accord avec nos collègues
sénateurs car elle repart des travaux de
qualité qu'ils ont menés sur le sujet au
début de l'année 2023 et qui ont ouvert
le chemin vers la présentation de ce
projet de loi constitutionnelle c'est la
raison pour laquelle je n'ai pas déposé
le moindre amendement et que je vous
inviterai à retenir la rédaction qui
nous est proposée cela n'enlève rien à
l'importance des débats que nous aurons
sur les amendements qui ont été déposés
qui nous permettront je le pense de
mettre en lumière l'objectif poursuivi
et les choix juridiques qui ont conduit
à cette rédaction cette révision
intervient dans un contexte mes chers
collègues qui inquiètent celles et ceux
qui défendent les droits des femmes
rappelons qu'en Europe et aux États-Unis
ce droit est menacé et partout à travers
le monde l'arrêt de la Cour suprême
américaine nous a rappelé que même dans
un pays aussi développé et attaché aux
liberté que les États-Unis un recul du
droit à l'avortement est possible je ne
transpose pas leur situation juridique à
notre pays mais force de constater que
ce droit comme disait Simon de
beauauvoir n'est jamais acquis et qu'il
peut suffir d'une crise pour que les
droits des femmes soient remis en cause
en Pologne en Hongrie les gouvernements
mettent en place et ont mis en place de
nouvelles barrières à l'accès à l'IVG
comme l'obligation d'écouter le cœur du
bébé ou l'interdiction d'avorter en cas
de malformation du féus le droit
européen ne nous apporte aucune garantie
par ailleurs en la matiè car la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme et la
Cour de justice de l'Union européenne
laisse une grande marge d'appréciation
aux États les militants dit antichoix
sont par ailleurs très actifs en France
et reçoivent d'importants financements
les entraves prennent des formes de plus
en plus pernicieuses certaines plateform
vont jusqu'à proposer des numéros verts
pour se faire passer pour des organismes
publics et dissuader ensuite les femmes
qui les appellent ne croyons donc pas
que la France est complètement
imperméable à ce risque et c'est
justement parce que ce droit est encore
solidement ancré en France qu'il faut le
protéger on ne peut on ne prend pas une
assurance quand la maison brûle par
cette révision la France enverrait un
message enfin fort dans le monde entier
en devenant le premier pays à
reconnaître l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse dans le texte de sa
constitution qui a servi de modèle à
tant d'autres pays à travers l'histoire
en somme pour conclure ce texte au fond
c'est rien et tout à la fois il n'est
rien parce qu'il ne vient pas
bouleverser le droit existant il n
touche pas mais il est tout parce qu'il
CR un bouclier non régressif pour le
futur en érigeant la liberté de recourir
à l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
parmi les libertés fondamental devant
être garanti par un État de droit au 21e
siècle je vous remercie
merci alors on va passer aux orateurs
des groupes on commence par Madame Sara
tanzili pour le groupe
Renaissance merci monsieur le président
monsieur le garde des saau monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers
collègues nous y sommes depuis le
premier jour de cette mandature nombre
d'entre nous parmi lesquels le groupe
Renaissance se sont mobilisés pour
consacrer dans notre Constitution le
droit des femmes de recourir à l'IVG
depuis le départ les initiatives
parlementaires parmi lesquelles celles
de la présidente berger ont toutes fait
valoir la nécessité de passer par un
projet de loi constitutionnel et appelit
le président de la République et le
gouvernement à agir nous voici donc
réuni pour cette étape cruciale qui est
l'examen de ce projet de loi
constitutionnel par notre commission à
ce stade je tiens à saluer monsieur le
garde des saau votre engagement constant
en faveur de l'inscription dans la
Constitution du droit de recourir à
l'IVG et la qualité du travail
légistique que vous avez entrepris comme
le soulligne l'avis éclairant du Conseil
d'État ainsi que le rapport établi par
le
rapporteur à ceux qui craignent que la
portée de cette constitutionnalisation
aille au-delà du cadre juridique actuel
je tiens à les rassurer le juge
constitutionnel a toujours eu prov
voocation de concilier les principes
constitutionnels il en fera de même
demain en conciliant notamment liberté
de recourir à l'IVG et liberté de
conscience la formulation retenu la loi
détermine les conditions dans lesquelles
s'exerce la liberté garantie à la femme
d'avoir recours à une interruption
volontaire de grossesse et son
inscription à l'article 34 de notre
Constitution consacre les prérogatives
du législateur pour délimiter les
contours et les modalité d'exercice de
ce droit dont la Constitution elle
protégera le caractère
effectif pour permettre aux deux
chambres de notre Parlement d'aboutir à
un accord et conformément aux
engagements pris le gouvernement a
proposé une rédaction de compromis à
ceux qui trouveraient que la rédaction
proposée par le Garde des saau pourrait
être améliorée je voudrais leur répondre
d'abord que le mieux est l'ennemi du
bien et qu'à la lecture de l'avis du
Conseil d'État mais également du rapport
de notre rapporteur dont je tiens à
souligner la qualité la formulation
permet sans nul doute de consacrer sur
le plan constitutionnel le droit des
femmes de recourir à l'IVG et que la
formulation liberté garantie a la même
valeur que celle de droit garanti
l'essentiel eston bien dans l'insertion
du terme
garantie la protection juridique
accordée sera donc équivalente à celle
proposée par les deux propositions de
loi constitutionnelles examiné l'an
dernier l'Assemblée nationale a déjà
exprimé sa volonté le Sénat dont je
tiens à souligner les travaux également
il n'est donc plus tant d'ergotter sur
une rédaction plus ou moins parfaite
mais d'acter que cette rédaction de
compromis atteint son objectif une loi
qui protège le droit à l'avortement et
qui établit un bouclier protecteur non
régressif mes chers collègues nous
n'avons jamais été aussi près de réussir
à consacrer ce droit essentiel du droit
des femmes il n'est plus tempants de
tergiverser il est temps d'agir parce
que le Conseil d'État reconnaît lui-même
qu'aucune garantie constitutionnelle ou
conventionnelle n'existe à ce jour pour
donner une portée supralégislative la
liberté des femmes de recourir à l'IVG
parce que l'humilité impose de regarder
avec lucidité ce qui se passe hors du
territoire français et de constater que
partout les réactionna les
réactionnaires lors qu'ils arrivent au
pouvoir porent atteinte à ce droit car
il constitue un pilier essentiel de la
capacité des femmes à maîtriser leur
corps et donc leur destin parce qu'il
faudrait être aveugle ou de mauvaise foi
pour ne pas voir que la menace est
réelle non les antiivg dans notre pays
n'ont pas disparu ils pululent sur les
réseaux sociaux et sur internet ils
envoient des féus en plastique aux
députés engagés sur cette question ils
défileront dans nos rues dimanche
prochain ils sont même parmi les rangs
de notre assemblée certain l'assument
franchement même aujourd'hui d'autres
beaucoup moins mais n'oublions pas que
si la stratégie de la cravate change
l'apparence elle ne change rien au fond
et que Marine Le Pen défendait il y a
encore quelques années le
déremboursement de l'IVG considérant
qu'il fallait lutter contre les
avortements de confort aussi c'est avec
bonheur en responsabilité dans la
perspective d'aboutir à la consécration
du droit des femmes de recourir à l'IVG
et d'envoyer un message d'espoir à
toutes les femmes du monde qui voient
leurs droit reproductif fragilisé que le
groupe Renaissance votera pour ce texte
sans modification je vous remercie merci
Madame Pascale borde pour le groupe
rassemblement national merci monsieur le
président monsieur le garde des saau
chers collègues dire que l'inscription
dans la Constitution de la liberté de la
femme de recourir à l'IVG est à ce jour
très éloignés des préoccupations
actuelles de la grande majorité de nos
concitoyens est un euphémisme tant les
esprits sont en effet en ce moment
tournés vers la hausse galopante des
prix de l'énergie et la baisse
corrélative du pouvoir d'achat ainsi que
vers une situation internationale plus
qu'inquiétante c'est également un texte
peu utile et ce pour des raison
conjoncturelle en effet personne ne
souhaite en France aujourd'hui dans la
classe politique remettre en cause
l'accès à l'IVG que ce soit dit il n'est
absolument pas menacé à l'heure où
234300 interruptions volontaires de
grossesse ont été réalisé en 2022
chiffre en constante augmentation ces
dernières années et qui est deux fois
plus élevé qu'en Allemagne c'est en
outre un texte peu utile pour des
raisons juridiques en effet la liberté
de la femme de recourir à une IVG comme
toute liberté quelle qu'elle soit ne
peut-être absolue car elle doit se
concilier avec d'autres libertés droits
et principes comme le principe de la
dignité humaine ou encore la liberté de
conscience des personnels de santé qui
est aussi une liberté constitutionnelle
par ailleurs cette inscription
nécessitera si elle est votée de
refondre une partie du du code de la
santé publique et du droit médical pour
assurer à tout prix cette nouvelle
liberté constitutionnelle ce qui au
regard de l'état actuel de notre système
de santé n'est pas souhaitable d'cun
mettent en avant l'aspect symbolique de
la démarche mais la Constitution n'est
pas un texte symbolique la Constitution
adoptée par le peuple par référendum en
58 à l'époque le référendum n'existait
pas que dans les livres cette
constitution fixe les principes
essentiels et les droits fondamentaux
qui permettent une vie en société à ce
titre certains constitutionnalistes
estiment qu'inscrire cette liberté dans
notre Constitution n'est pas responsable
car la norme constitutionnelle doit être
un point d'ancrage et notre droit un
élément de stabilité de l'ordre
juridique et non l'exutoire des désirs
de certains au demeurant comment peut-on
considérer que la liberté garantie à la
femme d'avoir recours à une IVG puisse
s'imposer comme un droit fondamental
alors que la liberté d'avoir recours à
une IVG n'é en réalité qu'une
possibilité dérogatoire au droit à la
vie qui est inscrit dans la loi veille
il y a là quelque chose qui ressort
d'une incompatibilité absolue alors
pourquoi ce texte qui n'est menacé par
personne et qui juridiquement ne
s'impose pas les auteurs de ce nouveau
projet tout en reconnaissant que la
liberté n'est nullement menacée dans
notre pays invoque désormais un
inventaire à à la préverre nous avons
tout d'abord une croisade que notre pays
se devrait d'entreprendre sur notre
continent et partout dans le monde comme
si nous n'avions pas assez de problèm en
France en second lieu il est invoqué le
fait que la France serait ainsi l'un des
premiers pays au monde et le premier en
Europe à reconnaître dans sa
constitution cette liberté bon et en
troisème leu la volonté du chef de
l'État d'adresser un message universel
de solidarité à toutes les femmes qui
voient aujourd'hui cette liberté bfou or
la sauvegarde des droits et libertés des
femmes ne se réduit pas à un sombre
concours pour savoir qui qui est le
premier ni à une croisade à travers le
monde et encore moins à un message
universel donné à la terre entière à
forceori lorsque ces mêmes droits et
libertés ne sont pas loin sans faux
efficients en France les femmes où
qu'elles vivent dans le monde méritent
mieux que cette vulgaire course à la
gloriole madame Mathilde panot pour le
groupe la France insoumise
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur
collègues alors que nous commençons
l'examen de ce texte je voudrais
rappeler que la législation sur l'IVG
n'a jamais été une évidence comme vient
de rappeler l'intervention de l'extrême
droite à l'instant cette législation est
née d'un long processus historique
d'acquisition de droits civils sociaux
et politiques pour les femmes en France
et je veux commencer par rendre hommage
à toutes les militantes les associations
sur le terrain dans les permanences qui
ont porté inlassablement ce combat dans
le temps long de l'histoire je veux
ainsi rendre hommage à l'Association
nationale pour l'étude de l'avortement à
choisir le Mouvement français pour le
planning familial au mouvement de
libération des femmes au mouvement pour
la liberté de l'avortement et de la
contraception et beaucoup d'autres que
je ne peux pas malheureusement pas
toutes citer je veux rendre hommage à
toutes celles et ceux qui hier et
aujourd'hui mènent toujours une lutte
sans repos pour les droits des femmes
cette victoire comme celle de 1975 et la
leure c'est leur victoire d'autant qu'
en 2024 49 ans après la le le vote de la
loi veille l'accès à l'IVG n'est
toujours pas pleinement effectif dans
notre pays ainsi en 2024 en France il
est toujours difficile pour certaines
femmes d'accéder à un avortement sûr
sécurisé et dans des délais convenables
en 2024 la double clause de conscience
n'est toujours pas abrogée en 2024
certaines femmes doivent faire encore
des dizaines et dizaines de kilomètres
pour avorter en 15 ans c'est 130 centres
IVG qui ont été fermés selon le planning
familial alors pourquoi parce que 49 ans
après le vote de la loi veille le combat
des femmes pour le droit à disposer de
leur corps et plus que jamais
d'actualité parce que 49 ans après le
vote de la loi veille monsieur le
ministre nous restons parfois dans un en
même temps insupportable a commencé
régulièrement par ce gouvernement
comment oublier qu'il y a 2 semaines le
5 janvier 2024 l'ancienne ministre de la
Santé Agnès firmain le baudau se rendait
à l'Institut le jeune qui milite
ouvertement contre l'avortement et le
droit à mourir dans la dignité comment
oublier que la nouvelle ministre de la
Santé Catherine Vautrin alors député alr
en 2017 saisissait le conseil
constitutionnel et lui demander de
censurer la loi relative à l'extension
du délit d'entrave à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse surtout comment
oublier qu'il y a seulement un mois le
décret est censé autoriser les
sages-femmes à pratiquer des IVG
instrumentales issu de la loi Gaillot et
si contraignant qu'il en contredit
l'objectif même de la loi faisant ainsi
régresser le droit à l'IVG je vous le
dis avec d'autant plus de force monsieur
le ministre qu'en France en Italie aux
États-Unis et dans beaucoup d'autres
pays du monde les antichois battent le
pavé avec bien souvent des victoires de
l'extrême droite à travers le monde leur
mot d'ordre et évidemment la régression
en en or pardon sera rendu demain le
verdict du procès de Vanessa Mendosa
Cortez militante pour le droit à
l'avortement dans un pays où l'IVG est
considéré comme un crime elle l' jugé
pour avoir dénoncé ce fait devant l'ONU
ainsi il est plus qu'urgent d'acter la
garantie de ce droit et par là d'envoyer
un signal aux femmes qui se battent dans
le monde entier le Manifeste des 343
affirmé la avortement libre et
gratuit n'est pas le but ultime de la
lutte des femmes au contraire il ne
correspond qu'à l'exigence la plus
élémentaire ce sans quoi le combat
politique ne peut même pas commencer
cette victoire est donc celle de
l'humanisme qui guide le principe de
l'action politique de mon groupe pour la
constitutionnalisation du droit à l'IVG
comme pour le droit à mourir dans la
dignité il n'y a pas de plus grande
liberté pour nous que celle d'être maîre
de son corps tout au long de sa vie
alors monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur pour terminer je voudrais
dire que nous ne sommes pas d'accord
avec la rédaction actuelle qui est
proposée mais que nous voterons ce texte
tel quel parce que je crois que nous
avons besoin urgemment de consacrer ce
droit fondamental humain dans la
Constitution pour les femmes de ce pays
et pour la aussi envoyer un message
d'encouragement à toutes celles qui se
battent en Argentine aux États-Unis en
Pologne en Hongrie en Italie dans bien
d'autres pays et que nous changerons
cette rédaction je l'espère dans la
constitution de la 6e république en
ajoutant son corollaire qui est le droit
à la
contraception madame Émilie Bonivard
pour le groupe les républicains merci
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Rapporteur chers
collègues avant d'examiner ce projet de
loi constitutionnel que vous présentez
aujourd'hui je souhaiterais rappeler la
lignée dans lequelle il s'inscrit
jusqu'en
1975 l'avortement constituait un délit
pénal sanctionné par 5 ans de prison les
médecins pouvaient être condamnés à une
interdiction d'exercer les Fes concerné
était contrainte de se rendre à
l'étranger ou de recourir à des
avortements clandestins avec tous les
risques que l'on connaît la
reconnaissance de l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse a été le fruit
d'un long combat des femmes et des
hommes qui l'ont soutenu aujourd'hui le
droit à l'interruption volontaire de de
grossesse fait partie intégrante de
notre patrimoine juridique fondamental
et nous nous en
félicitons cependant la question qui se
pose aujourd'hui est de savoir si la
protection constitutionn de l'IVG en
France est suffisamment solide et
durable ou si une inscription dans la
Constitution est nécessaire et le
corollaire à cette question c'est
également si l'inscription dans cette
constitution n'ouvre pas un risque de
rompre l'équilibre porté par la loi
veille entre le droit à l'avortement et
le droit de l'enfant la liberté le droit
de l'enfant à naître c'est ce que nous
examinerons c'est la protection de cet
équilibre euh avec cette inscription
dans la Constitution euh il faut le
rappeler il n'y a pas aujourd'hui de
risque de revinement de la jurisprudence
sur l'avortement en France c'est
important que nous le rappelions la
décision de la Cour suprême des
États-Unis n'a aucun impact sur la
France où le droit à l'avortement tel
qu'il est prévu par la loi veille n'est
pas menacé tous les avis du Conseil
constitutionnel l'indiquent et dem un de
nos droits fondamentaux il fait l'objet
d'une grande unanimité au sein de nos
groupes politiques en France à part
certains comme nous venons de de
l'entendre je pense l'IVG figure dans
notre droit depuis 75 et n'a eu de cesse
d'être renforcé depuis le Conseil
constitutionnel a toujours jugé conforme
à la Constitution par quatre fois s'est
prononcé en sa faveur et en faveur de
son élargissement en 75 2001 2014 et
2016 donc même sans inscription de l'IVG
dans la Constitution il est fortement
probable que le Conseil constitutionnel
jugerait une loi interdissant ou
restreint l'IVG comme non conforme à la
Constitution puisqu'elle priverait de
garantie légale cette liberté de la
femme garantie par l'article 2 de la DDH
c'est de
1789 donc on peut s'interroger sur le
fait qu'on soit de l'ordre du symbole
que l'on envoie des des signaux au monde
c'est important la France a un rôle à
jouer mais attention à ne pas
instrumentaliser notre loi fondamentale
dans un un objectif de diplomatie
internationale ou en tout cas si nous le
faisons il faut éviter que un risque
incertain qui est le le risque du
recours à l'IVG en France se transforme
en un risque nouveau en matière
juridique et d'ouverture de contentieux
sur la question de
l'IVG selon l'exposé des motifs cette
révision de la Constitution vise comme
je l'ai dit à adresser un message
universel et de solidarité aux femmes
qui voit leur liberté bafoué mais je
souhaite le rappeler siim veille pardon
elle-même en décembre 2008 n'avait pas
recommandé de modifier le préambule ni
d'intégrer à la constitution de droits
et liberté lié à la bioéthique laquelle
intégrait l'IVG et siimon veille avait
refusé d'y inscrire des dispositions
avait indiqué qu'il fallait refuser d'y
inscrire des disposition de porter
purement symbolique les députés LR sont
attachés à l'équilibre de la loi veille
de 75 qui repose sur la conciliation
entre la liberté des femmes et la
protection de l'enfant à naître nous
aurons donc beaucoup de questions sur
l'articulation de la garantie que vous
indiquez dans cet article de la garantie
de cette liberté l'articulation
avec le la liberté de conscience des
médecins et également le droit des
droits de l'enfant à naître je vous
remercie monsieur Baladan pour le groupe
démocrate merci monsieur Président
Monsieur le gardeessau mes chers
collègues alors clin d'œil de l'histoire
demain alors que notre commission
débattra du projet de loi
constitutionnel relatif à la liberté de
recourir à l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse cela fera 49 ans que la loi
veille aura été promulguée donnant ainsi
aux femmes la liberté de disposer de
leur corps et de choisir leur maternité
depuis plusieurs lois ont élargi et
amélioré le cadre de prise en charge de
l'IVG malheureusement ce droit que nous
pensons fondamental et able n'est pas à
l'abri de régression ou pire
d'abrogation les multiples atteintes en
Europe et en outreAtlantique en sont la
triste réalité l'onde de choc provoqué
par la décision historique de la Cour
suprême américaine bouleverse nos
convictions et brise le mouvement que
l'on croyait continu des progrès du
droit des femmes à disposer de leur
corps alors les paroles de Simon de
Beauvoir à Claudine monte mont diplomate
et signataire du manifeste des TR 3 au
lendemain de l'adoption de la loi veille
à l'Assemblée nationale son criante de
vérité nous pouvons gagner mais
temporairement il suffira d'une crise
politique économi et religieuse pour que
les droits des femmes nos droits soient
remis en question votre vie durant vous
devrez demeurer
vigilante cette vigilance est en réalité
l'affaire de toutes et de tous femme et
homme député de tout bord elle est aussi
notre affaire nous devons nous
interroger sur notre capacité cité a
anticipé de tels revers en France et il
est de notre devoir de protéger la
liberté de recourir à l'IVG de toute
crise politique économique et religieuse
rappelons que si nous débattons
aujourd'hui c'est que le droit à l'IVG
ne bénéficie pas de la protection la
plus forte qui soit son inscription dans
notre norme suprême et je n'oublie pas
que le Conseil constitutionnel depuis
2011 a rattaché la liberté de recourir à
l'IVG à la liberté de la femme qui
découle de l'article 2 de la Déclaration
des droits de l'homme et du citoyen
cependant il lui a jamais été conféré de
valeur
constitutionnelle symbolle diront les
uns véritable protection diront les
autres il n demeure pas moins que la
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG
permettra de se prémunir de toute
véléité de remise en cause de cette
liberté par la loi et alors que 82 % des
Français et des Françaises évidemment se
déclarent favorable à cette
constitutionnalisation
elle serait par ailleurs un signal fort
et utile pour le reste du monde car à ce
jour aucune constitution ne reconnaît de
ce droit de façon positive le 24
novembre 2022 notre Assemblée a adopté à
une large majorité transpartisane une
proposition de loi constitutionnelle
garantissant aux femmes l'effectivité de
l'IVG ainsi que son égal accès le 1er
février 2023 le Sénat adopte à son tour
cette proposition de loi avec une
nouvelle rédaction le texte qui qui nous
est proposé aujourd'hui est le fruit
d'un équilibre entre nos deux positions
retenant les mots interruption
volontairees de grossesse afin de ne
laisser subsister aucune ambiguïé
consacrant l'existence d'une liberté et
reconnaissant le rôle du Parlement dans
l'établissement des conditions dans
lesquelles s'exerce cette liberté
garantie par la Constitution
gouvernement politique élus citoyens je
crois qu'un même élan nous étreint tous
désormais alors si nous actons que nous
avons un consensus pour réviser la
Constitution cela ne doit pas se faire à
la légère et le groupe démocrate salue à
ce titre la décision du Président de la
République de recourir à un projet de
loi constitutionnelle et de ce fait à un
vote des parlementaires réunis en
congrès je vous
remercie madame Marie Noël btistel pour
le groupe
socialiste merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur chers collègues 49 ans après
l'adoption de la loi veille ce texte
institutionnel qui traite d'un sujet
sociétal venant mobiliser les
consciences de chacun et en particulier
celle des femmes est très attendu en
2018 déjà nous avions présenté un
amendement à la réforme
constitutionnelle afin de reconnaître
dans le préambule de la constitution de
46 le droit d'avir accès à une
contraception adaptée et gratuite ainsi
que de recourir librement à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
en 2019 nous reprenions cet amendement
sous la forme d'une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle qui n'avait pas obtenu
alors l'aval de la majorité mais ce
projet de loi constitutionnel qui
inscrit l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse dans notre norme fondamentale
est un acte profondément politique qui
vient traduire juridiquement la volonté
de la communauté nationale d'inscrire
dans les règles qui régissent son
fonctionnement la possibilité pour la
femme de disposer librement de son corps
nul doute que la portée de nos propos
aujourd'hui raésonnera bien au-delà des
mur de notre commission pour des
milliers de femmes à travers le monde le
renversement de l'arrêt de la par la
Cour suprême américaine la mobilisation
de toutes les associations féministes le
dépôt de six propositions de loi ainsi
que l'adoption par les deux chambres
d'un projet visant à la
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG ont
poussé le président de la République à
s'engager en ce sens alors si ce projet
de loi constitutionnel n'est pas parfait
dans sa rédaction nous ne pouvons que
nous en satisfaire nous en satisfaire
d'abord car il vient répondre à un enjeu
politique celui de créer un bouclier
contre une régression de la liberté de
recourir à l'IVG à ceux qui opposent
qu'il n'existe pas de menace imminente
sur le droit d'avorter en France nous
opposons le contre-exemple des SEP États
américains ayant interdit l'IVG même en
cas de viol ou d'inceste celui de la
Pologne où désormais seuls les IVG en
cas de viol ou de danger pour la vie de
la mer sont autorisé de la Hongrie qui
oblige désormais les femmes souhaitant
avorter à écouter le battre le cœur du
fettus l'inexistence de tel risques en
France aujourd'hui ne serait pour autant
préjugé du maintien d'un statut quo
autant que les entraves à l'IVG prennent
des formes de plus en plus pernicieuses
de la part des mouvements antichoix qui
trompent les femmes peu ou mal informées
pour les inciter à poursuivre leur
grossesse nous en satisfire ensuite car
il vient répondre à un enjeu juridique
celui de garantir une protection qui est
aujourd'hui absente au niveau
constitutionnel et européen la
constitutionnalisation créerait ainsi
une base juridique robuste en droit
interne en permettant que la survenance
d'une loi régressive puisse être
censurée par le Conseil constitutionnel
enfin nous en satisfaire car il vient
répondre à un enjeu sociétal de garantir
aux femmes la nécessaire libre
disposition de leur corps afin d'assurer
une égalité réelle pleine et entière
entre les femmes et les hommes alors oui
la rédaction est perfptible nous aurions
préféré la consécration d'un droit
plutôt que celle d'une liberté afin de
garantir un véritable droit fondamental
à l'IVG sans qu'il soit rattaché à la
liberté personnelle nous aurions nous
n'aurions pas introduit l'IVG à
l'article 34 mais plutôt à l'article 1er
article écrain des droits nous aurions
souhaité que la contraception y figure
également mais nous savons que les
victoires féministes ont toujours été le
fruit de compromis sans accommodement
Simon veille ne serait pas parvenu à
faire adopter la loi sur l'avortement 50
ans plus tard c'est toujours le cas nous
tenons toutefois à insister sur deux
points monsieur le ministre tout d'abord
sur la notion indispensable de garantie
de la vie des constitutionnalistes que
nous avons éditionné l'absence du mot
garantie aurait pour conséquence la
limit de limiter la révision au droit du
au rappel du droit existant à savoir la
compétence du législateur pour définir
le cadre applicable à l'IVG rendrez la
formulation imprécise et créerz une
incertitude juridique sur l'intention
initiale de législateur ensuite la
mention du terme femme qui ne doit pas
être interprété comme excluant vis-à-vis
des personnes transjar par exemple parce
que nous savons que cette rédaction est
le résultat d'un compromis avec le Sénat
parce qu'il est important de mettre
sévèrement en échec les Provis et
d'avancer collectivement sur la
protection de ce droit parce que des
millions de femmes partout dans le monde
nous attendent nous avons donc opté pour
une position responsable acceptant le
compromis et ne déposant pas
d'amendement je vous remercie Madame
Anne Cécile violent pour le groupe au
raison merci monsieur le président
monsieur le garde des saau monsieur le
rapporteur chers collègues le 24 juin
2022 outre atlantique la Cour suprême
des États-Unis rendait une décision
relative à l'interruption de grossesse
qui envoya une onde de choc à travers le
monde en mettant en terme à sa célèbre
jurisprudence RAW versus Wade de
1973 la Cour suprême a démontré la
fragilité des droits fondamentaux qui
semblaient acquis dans nos sociétés
modernes en Europe aussi certains
courants tentent d'entraver la liberté
des femmes d'interrompre leur grossesse
la France fort heureusement est
aujourd'hui dans une situation très
éloignée de celle des États-Unis le
droit à l'IVG ne fait plus aujourd'hui
l'objet d'aucune remise en cause par les
partis politiques de tout bord certes
des mouvements concentrés et
relativement minoritaires portent
toujours une voix provie notre réaction
à l'évolution de ce droit doit donc être
mesuré néanmoins face à ce retour en
arrière nous devons montrer l'exemple
consacrer cette liberté au sommet de la
hiérarchie des normes ferait de la
France l'un des premiers pays au monde
et le premier en Europe à protéger au
sein de sa constitution la santé
physique et psychique des femmes contre
les risques que présente un avortement
dans la clandestinité en héritier de
Simone veille nous nous prémunirions
ainsi contre la possibilité d'un retour
au feuse aux feuseuses d'ange près de 50
ans après la loi fondatrice du 17
janvier 1975 en empêchant la remise en
cause par la loi de la liberté d'avoir
recours à l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse c'est un message fort envoyé
au au hommes et aux femmes du monde
entier la pertinence de l'inscription de
cette liberté dans notre Constitution a
été confirmée par l' vie du 7 décembre
2023 rendu par le Conseil d'État
celui-ci a noté que la liberté de
recourir à l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse ne fait aujourd'hui l'objet
d'aucune consécration en tant que telle
dans la Constitution française dans la
Convention européenne de sauvegarde des
droits de l'homme et des libertés
fondamentales ou en droit de l'Union
européenne elle n'est pas d'avantage
Consac é par la jurisprudence de la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme ou de
la Cour de justice de l'Union européenne
qui renvoie toutes deux à l'appréciation
des états la recherche d'équilibre entre
le droit à la vie privée de la mère et
la protection de l'enfant à être dans sa
décision du 27 juin 2001 le Conseil
constitutionnel a fait le choix
d'adosser la valeur constitutionnelle de
la liberté de la femme de recourir à
l'IVG à celle de la liberté de la femme
prévue par l'article 2 de la Déclaration
des droits de l'homme et des citoyens
dès lors le groupe horizon et apparenté
est favorable au projet de loi
constitutionnel relatif à la liberté de
recourir à l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse en ce qu'il insère à l'article
34 de la Constitution un alinéa qui
précise que la loi détermine les
conditions dans lesquelles s'exerce la
liberté garantie à la femme d'avoir
recours à une interruption volontaire de
grossesse la rédaction choisie emporte
notre approbation car elle précise que
c'est à la loi de garantir l'effectivité
et la l'accès à l'IVG en d'autres termes
qu'il revient au représentants de la
nation de déterminer les conditions dans
lesquelles ce droit est exercé ainsi la
liberté de recourir à l'IVG sera
protégée de façon pérenne tout en
continuant à être encadré par un
processus démocratique d'autre part
l'emploi d'une formule positive permet
d'assurer la constitutionnalité d'un
certain nombre de dispositifs important
dans notre droit et notamment la clause
de conscience des médecins et des
sagesfemmes
le groupe horizon tient enfin à saluer
le fait que la rédaction retenue soit
une synthèse de compromis des écritures
adoptées dans les deux chambres
résolument attaché à la liberté de
choisir notre groupe parlementaire sera
toujours guidé par la volonté d'empêcher
une quelconque remise en cause de
l'équilibre défini par la loi Veil nous
voterons donc en faveur de ce projet de
loi constitutionnel dans la rédaction
proposée je vous remercie madame Samra
regol pour le groupe écologiste merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre oui ça a été dit répété les
conquêtes féministes sont fait de l'IVG
une liberté en France un droit des
femmes a décidé de leur corps et donc de
leur vie c'est pas un combat récent
c'est un combat de nos aînés ces
féministes qui ont été vilipandés pour
avoir les motro ces avorteuses ces
faiseuses d'anges qui étaient poursuivi
par la justice et dont aujourd'hui
l'histoire reconnaît l'apport et comment
elles ont pu sauver des vies ces femmes
c'estes féministes elles étaient de tout
bord mais elles partageaient un combat
commun elles ont trac c'est le sillon
qui nous amène aujourd'hui à ce texte ce
texte qui est une suuite mais
certainement pas une finalité il n'est
qu'un qu'une étape dans le long
processus qui est celui de notre
empouvoirement car oui comme toujours
nos droits peuvent être mis en danger il
le sont aujourd'hui ils le sont dès lors
qu'ils ne sont pas institués on pense
naturellement aux USA la Pologne on l'a
répété ici à tous ces pays où en fait la
bascule politique produit une fracture
directement dans le socle fondamentaux
de nos droits et où les femmes sont
toujours toujours les premières victimes
mais en France aussi c'est existe les
collègues en ont parl également ces
fauxites d'aide aux femmes qui qui dans
lesqueles pardon il s'agit
principalement de les orienter vers un
refus de leur droits et en refus de leur
choix je pense également à cette
campagne dont on est ici nombreuse à
avoir été victime des réseaux antivg des
réseaux antidroit qui pour nous menacer
nous faire peur ou je sais pas pourquoi
d'ailleurs nous envoyé des fétus en
plastique par la poste que d'argent si
mal dépensé en tout cas celle enfin en
tout cas on est quelques-unes ici en
avoir été les victimes je pense
également et surtout à ces déserts
médicaux qui font que l'accès à l'IVG
n'est géographiquement pas une égalité
je pense encore plus à ces médecins ces
gynécologues qui aujourd'hui encore
culpabilisent les femmes tentent de les
faire revenir sur leur choix ces
médecins contre lesquels on bute parfois
on sait combien dans nos proches dans
nos circonscriptions dans nos familles
ou même dans ces assemblées combien en
ont été victimes beaucoup trop
malheureusement et aujourd'hui encore
alors il y a un point commun à toutes
ces menaces un point commun qui est très
politique et nous y revenons c'est le
choix des réactionnaires le choix des
réactionnaires que de toujours empêcher
les femmes de disposer de leur corps
parce que cette liberté làà est une
liberté contre laquelle toujours il
s'oppos c'est le choix de les tenir à
distance et quelque part de les tenir en
laisse pour éviter qu'ell puisse décider
de leur avenir et que collectivement
nous décidions de notre avenir en notre
assemblée d'ailleurs certains sont sont
encore à légiférer sur le ventre des
femmes pour nous obliger à produire
selon certains quotat ce les mêmes qui
opposent les droits des femmes à ceux
d'un fétus ceux qui refusent de
construire l'histoire de demain
l'histoire des femmes et de la France al
constitutionnalisé ce n'est pas banalisé
ça a déjà été dit c'est sanctuarisé en
droit celui des femmes ce n'est pas
démultiplier les recours à l'IVG ce
n'est pas nier le choix de celles qui ne
veulent pas y recourir c'est s'assurer
que quoi qu'il arrive l'histoire ne se
déroulera pas à rebours et que nos
droits ne repartiront pas c'est aussi
inscrire la France dans l'Histoire celle
du premier pays à agir pour une part de
constitutionnalisation de ce droit alors
certes nous aurions préféré la
formulation travaillée par notre
collègue Mathilde Panau celle qui
permettait de garantir l'accès au droit
et incluait dans sa version première le
droit à la contraception on aurait pu
imaginer aussi
constitutionnaliser le délai à 14
semaines donc nous porterons quand même
des AM pour pouvoir reparler de pourquoi
est-ce qu'on ne peut pas aller jusque là
de pourquoi est-ce qu'encore une fois
nous nous autolimitons mais au-dessus
tout il y a un objectif qui prime et un
seul c'est d'arriver à avancer c'est
d'arriver à construire cette histoire
c'est d'arriver à au moins
constitutionnaliser F à l'article 34 fus
revu à la baisse ce droit fondamental de
toutes les femmes en France qu'ell soit
française ou que ne le soit pas parce
que ces droits pour nous constituent les
droits fondamentaux pour tout notre
peuple
merci Madame Elsa fossillon pour le
groupe Gauche démocrate et
républicaine merci Monsieur le le
président monsieur le ministre chers
collègues au groupe GDR comme beaucoup
ici nous ne pensons pas que que cette
loi soit veine ou uniquement cosmétique
ou symbolique comme d'autres l'ont dit
ici elle est à notre sens profondément
utile sur le plan social médical
politique culturel et elle est
évidemment peut-être encore un peu plus
à l'heure de la montée en puissance de
nouveaux fascisme à l'échelle européenne
mais c'est vrai aussi ailleurs dans le
monde il faut le rappeler il y a encore
47000 femmes par an dans le monde qui
meurent d'un avortement clandestin soit
une femme toutes les 9
minutes ce projet de loi de
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG est
attendu de très longuees dates
il faut d'ailleurs noter à quel point
pour l'ensemble des luttes féministes
pour l'ensemble des luttes pour
conquérir de nouveaux droits pour les
femmes à chaque fois il faut des années
à quel point il faut toujours des des
luttes extrêmement longue et combien il
faut à la fin y compris toujours faire
preuve de compromis c'est quelque part
la marque de fabrique à chaque fois des
grandes conquêtes féministes et je veux
évidemment saluer tout celles qui se
sont battu pour que nous en arrivions là
aujourd'hui et toutes celles qui vont
continuer à le faire pour que nous
ouvrions encore pour de nouvelles
conquêtes et de nouveaux droits il y a
de très nombreuses associations qui
continuent d' vraer pour le droit à
l'avortement mais pour son effectivité
aussi réelle en France je pense aussi à
toutes celles et ceux qui ont souhaité
au Parlement et bien se saisir de cette
de cette question et de s'assurer de la
protection absolue de ce droit notamment
depuis l'annulation de l'arrêt R contre
W par la Cour suprême américaine et qui
a eu une résonance internationale
d'ailleurs je je note à quel point et
bien ce combat pour le droit à l'vg à
travers le monde a toujours une
résonance et et je crois que c'est
presque uniquement pour ce sujet en
particulier que cette résonance prend
cette ampleur là on a vu que dans
certains pays d'ailleurs au Kenya au
Nigeria en Éthiopie ou en en Inde des
mouvements
anti avortement ont saisit l'opportunité
de l'annulation par la Cour suprême
américaine pour parvenir à l'arrêt de
processus législative progressiste en
faveur des droits sexuels et
reproductifs donc je pense qu'elle a
évidemment cette
constitutionnalisation une valeur
extrêmement importante pour les droits
des femmes en France mais je n néglige
pas et je suis même fière qu'elle puisse
avoir une résonance ailleurs dans le
monde en France je le dis ce séisme
outratlantique a réouvert le débat
autour de la constitutionnalisation de
l'IVG selon un sondage pour la Fondation
des femmes et le planning février le
planning familial de février 2021 93 %
des Français se disent attachés au droit
à l'avortement pourtant cela ne nuit pas
à la vigueur des associations provie
abreué de financement certes opaqu mais
aussi très nombreux ces associations se
pai des campagnes régulières et
impactantes manifestation antiviégés
diffusion de fausses informations auprès
des femmes sur Internet mobilisation
d'élus réactionnaires les Provis
redoublent de créativité pour empêcher
les femmes d'avorter il y a donc c'est
une forme de réponse à celles et ceux
qui nous expliquent qu'ici il n'y aurait
pas de danger d'abord je pense qu'il y
en a mais tant mieux s'il n'y en a pas
alors protégeons absolument
ce droit à l'IVG j'ai été bien trop
longue je veux simplement dire
queévidemment la formulation actuelle ne
nous convient pas qu'elle est
perfectible que nous aurons des
amendements et que nous pensons pouvoir
continuer à en débattre et que c'est
utile mais qu'évidemment nous voterons
la constitutionnalisation de
l'IVG et enfin Monsieur Jean-Félix àa
pour le groupe liberté indépendant outre
M et territoire merci monsieur le
président monsieur le garde des saau mes
chers collègues il est important d'être
constant et de rester fidèle à ses
convictions
plus d'un an après le vote de la
dernière proposition de loi sur le thème
la position de la très grande majorité
de notre groupe n'a pas changé nous
restons favorable plus que jamais à
l'inscription dans notre constitution du
droit à l'IVG pour toutes les femmes ce
projet de loi de réelle chance d'aboutir
c'est une fenêtre de tir assez inespéré
qui se présente et nous ne pouvons pas
la manquer les avancées consacrées par
la loi veille il y a 49 ans sont
désormais soutenu par une immense
majorité de nos concitoyens il est temps
évidemment d'aller plus loin je
commencerai en répondant à ceux qui
estiment que notre droit est
suffisamment protecteur je le dirai que
l'optimisme est une qualité mais qu' ne
doit pas mener à l'aveuglement la loi
veille est sans doute une grande loi
elle nen reste pas moins une loi
ordinaire qui pourrait être limitée nous
le savons tous par une autre loi
ordinaire à ceux qui disent qu'il
n'existe pas de risqu réel et éminemment
politique je répondrai que l'improbable
n'est pas impossible s'il existe une
majorité dès à présent pour voter ce
texte alors cela doit nous pousser non
pas l'inaction mais à renforcer la
protection de ce droit nous envenons la
rédaction que vous nous proposez
monsieur le garde des saau nous
pourrions vous reprocher effectivement
une prudence excessive l'article unique
reste selon nous un peu timide par
rapport à la rédaction adoptée par notre
assemblée en novembre 2022 à ce stade
notre groupe rejoint d'autres groupes
sur quelques remarques le projet retient
le terme de liberté c'est un débat que
nous avons eu que nous aurons encore et
non celui de droit ce choix bien
qu'évoqué par ailleurs n'est quand même
pas à
Odin nous ne tenons pas à rentrer dans
les débat de juristes vous vous l'aveaz
déjà dit le Conseil d'État lui-même
considère que ces termes sont
interchangeables en la matière cependant
nous parlons de notre Constitution le
choix des mots et le signal que l'on
envoie aux femmes est important un droit
c'est une garantie réelle offerte à une
personne qui en a besoin et il nous
semble que ce terme est plus approprié
nous estimons surtout qu'il faudrait
aller plus loin et retenir la rédaction
adoptée par l'autre assemblée pourquoi
en effet ne pas inscrire un droit
effectif dont légal accès est garanti à
tous il existe encore de nombreux
clivages en particulier des fractures
territoriales dans la accès à l'IVG ce
texte ne doit pas se limiter au symboles
il doit aussi ouvrir la voie des
avancées concrètes pour que toutes les
femmes se trouvant sur le territoire
puissent avoir accès à l'IVG dans les
mêmes conditions nous pensons que notre
commission effectivement gagnerait à
être plus ambitieuse on ne modifie pas
la la Constitution tous les jours et
nous devons être à la hauteur des
attentes des citoyens et citoyennes qui
nous écoutent aujourd'hui néanmoins nous
nous associons à l'élan de
responsabilité qui traverse la plupart
des bandes des groupes d'Aujour
aujourd'hui en insistant sur le fait que
ce qui compte c'est quand même d'aboutir
au renforcement de la protection de ce
droit par l'inscription dans la
Constitution je vous remercie alors j'ai
donné la parole au garde desau pour la
réponse aux orateurs des groupes avant
le rapporteur et ensuite les questions
qui sont inscrites merci monsieur le
Président je je je veux remercier Anne
Cécile violent qui a rappelé les termes
du Conseil d'État Conseil d'État il nous
dit quoi ben il nous dit que la liberté
de recourir à l'interruption volontaire
de grossesse n'est garantie par
rien ni par la Constitution nous le
savons c'est c'est l'objet de notre
réunion de nos travaux ni par le Conseil
constitutionnel ni par la Convention
européenne de sauvegarde par sa
jurisprudence ni par la Cour de justice
de
l'Union à soit seul et de façon
intrinsèque ça justifie que nous
inscrivions la liberté et la garantie de
la liberté dans la Constitution car le
Conseil d'État nous le rappelle à toutes
et à tous ça n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui madame bord un tout petit
mot je je vais être rapide et je suis
sommé de lettre par votre
président qui est le maître des
horloges symbolique la Constitution mais
dois-je vous rappeler que c'est dans la
Constitution que la couleur du drapeau
que la langue française que notre dev
est inscrite donc il y a aussi une
portée symbolique elle est extrêmement
importante dans la période que nous
traversons il est important de dire dans
le texte le plus haut que la liberté et
non fait non mais c'est oui pourtant de
disposer de son corps pour une femme
entre dans la constitution et puis moi
l'universalisme la France des Lumières
moi je suis toujours heureux fier et ému
quand la France des Lumières peut
éclairer le monde entier et dire que ça
vient de chez nous d'un travail
transpartisan à ce propos de mots il
sont pas des mots de flagornerie je suis
pas un flagorneur merci Madame Panau de
dire à la fois le texte vous l'aimez pas
bien mais qu'au fond vous allez le voter
et vous avez raison je ve dire pourquoi
et je vais vous dire quelle a été notre
méthode le président de la République
avait dit d'abord on va suivre avec
beaucoup d'intérêt de de de de
bienveillance les initiatives
parlementaires bon les initiatives
parlementaires elles ont abouti le texte
madame pano que vous avez présenté je
l'ai soutenu Aurore Berger a retiré son
texte puis on est allé au Sénat bon
Sénat il y avait le texte de Madame
Vogel il y a toute une discussion
qu'est-ce qu'il y a de commun énormément
de choses mais il y a quelques
divergences sémantiques avec lesquels je
suis obligé de composer donc c'était
très bien que d'abord il y ait un
travail parlementaire
et qu'ensuite le
Gouvernement présente un texte
susceptible d'être adopté par les deux
assemblée je rappelle que en des termes
identiques c'est pas et je ne fais
allusion à rien d'autre c'est pas en CMP
que ça va se réglé hein il y a pas de
navette là bon il y a l'Assemblée il y a
le Sénat termes identiques et le Congrès
donc vous êtes pas tout à fait contente
du texte je l'entends c'était pas le
vôtre et au Sénat on était pas tout à
fait content du texte de l'Assemblée
c'était pas l'heure mais quand même
quand on regarde et quand on regarde en
plus le petit ajout sémantique du
Conseil d'État on a un texte extrêmement
équilibré et c'est maintenant ou jamais
si j'ose dire où on joue ce jeu on est
transpartisan on là et on fait une œuvre
collective qui vient de de qui est né au
Parlement et qui se terminera au
Parlement
ou bien on on on le fait capoter pour un
mot pour une virgule je je vous engage
l'impératif mais totalement interdit
lorsque je m'adresse à vous mais de lire
laave du Conseil d'État il est
extrêmement bien fait il est extrêmement
clair et notamment madame la députée
Bonivard sur ces question d'équilibre le
Conseil d'État est on ne peut plus clair
je veux pas allonger les choses mais y a
il y a tout un paragraphe que le Conseil
d'État consacre à l'analyse de ce texte
pour dire mais les grands équilibres les
grands enjeux on va pas les toucher du
tout tout donc moi je je mais non mais
madame roulau vous faites non non non
non je vais vous le lire vous allez me
contraindre à le lire
mais le Conseil d'État considère que par
elle-même l'inscription de la liberté de
recourir à une IVG dans la Constitution
dans les termes que propose le
gouvernement ne remet pas en cause les
autres droits et libertés que la
Constitution garantit et le Conseil
d'État va développer et il va notamment
envisager la liberté de conscience qui
soutend la liberté des médecins des
sagesfemmes à ne pas pratiquer une IVG
ainsi que la liberté d'expression donc
les choses me paraissent tout à fait
claires on est sur du consensuel on est
sur du transpartisan on est sur un
équilibre que je pense nous avons
trouvé en avant toute c'est très
important alors maintenant sur les
risques les jamais jamais jamais mais
jamais quoi qui aurait envisagé alors
évidemment on dit mais oui mais
l'Atlantique nous sépare c'est très très
loin c'est un autre pays oui enfin il y
a 50 ans que ça durait c'est fini la
Hongrie la Pologne et des gens qui
envoient encore notamment au députés des
féus en plastique donc il y a dans ce
pays des forces qui n'ont aucune envie
aucune
envie de l'avortement et et et de cette
liberté fondamentale pour les femmes et
je le dis sans incriminer N qui que ce
soit al je pense que ça aussi c'est bien
au-delà des des des parties mais il se
trouve essentiellement à l'extrême
droite ensuite chacun y retrouve les
siens ou pas mais c'est une réalité elle
a été exprimé tout à l'heure par Sara
tanzili
donc voilà on a un grand texte de
liberté c'est pas tous les jours qu'on
peut tous
ensemble préparer porter V en ce qui
vous concerne un texte de liberté alors
soit on choisit de chipoter mais c'est
pas ce que j'ai entendu aujourd'hui soit
on consacre ce texte on va l'inscrire
dans la dans la Constitution dans notre
Constitution et ce sera oui le Conseil
d'État a cru utile de le rappeler madame
fussillon vous vous vous vous en avez
dit un mot la première fois qu'un pays
inscrit dans sa constitution cette
liberté si j'étais familier je vous
dirais ça de la gueule si je le suis
moins je peux vous dire ça quand même
beaucoup
d'allure monsieur le
rapporteur merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre ch chers collègues
d'abord merci à toutes et à tous pour
pour vos interventions vos remarques
préliminaires et les questionnements qui
sont derrière d'abord peut-être
reprendre un des mots qui sera important
du f une attitude qui doit guider je
pense tous nos travaux durant durant les
semaines qui viennent à l'Assemblée
comme au Sénat une invitation que nous
transmettait notre collègue saratanzili
qui touche à l'humilité et je remercie
effectivement l'ensemble des collègues
qui pouvaient porter d'autres rédaction
avec humilité de rentrer dans ce débat
et de faire passer effectivement avant
l'enjeu de l'accord avec le Sénat en
regardant la qualité aussi des apports
qui ont été faits par nos collègues
sénateurs parce que c'est ce qui nous
permettra je pense à la fin d'arriver à
cette
constitutionnalisation bien entendu
ensuite revenir sur vos propos madame
bord alors nous sommes en desésaccord
effectivement assez certain vous
considèrez que c'est pas utile qu'il n'y
a pas d'attaque nous considérons oui
aujourd'hui qu'il y a des attaques pas
que ailleurs dans le monde ou en Europe
en France aussi et qui justifie dans un
moment où il y a un accord de
l'assemblée du Sénat un soutien fort de
nos concitoyenes et nos concitoyens et
bien oui de porter la
protection de ce droit au niveau
constitutionnel et de le faire
aujourd'hui si possible le plus
rapidement possible al quand je dis le
plus rapidement possible peut-être petit
point de détail l'objectif n'est pas une
date à atteindre si ça doit être fait en
mars ce sera en mars et ce sera très
bien si c'est en avril en mai et bien ce
sera très bien aussi l'objectif c'est
d'aboutir dessus dans le respect bien
entendu du travail des deux chambres par
ailleurs madame bord et pour rebondir
sur d'autres propos qui ont été
faits à travers cette
constitutionnalisation c'est bien une
liberté publique que nous allons
reconnaître parce que tous les travaux
qui ont été faits en fait sur la
reconnaissance de l'avortement ont été
fait via le code pénal et via une
exception donc d'une certaine manière
une tolérance et bien oui avec les
travaux que nous menons ici la
constitutionnalisation nous allons
reconnaître une liberté publique
fondamentale celle de disposer de son
corps et je pense que c'est un message
d'égalité de d'égalité des droits qui
oui est majeur et qui envoie un message
aux générations présente future celle de
deain et puis au monde au monde entier
petit point technique vous avez il est
important évoquer le fait que cette
constitutionnalisation entraînerait je
cite une refonte totale enfin importante
du code de la santé publique alors non
regarde je vous invite à lire le
considérant numéro 12 de l'av du Conseil
d'État qui dit parfaitement que ce texte
n'implique pas de de modifications
législativ donc ça n'entraînera pas de
modification du code de la santé
publique je rebondirai sur
l'intervention de notre collègue bonivar
que je remercie pour salu un point qui
va être un point clé de nos débats
demain à travers les amendements
évidemment
sur la confrontation avec la protection
du Conseil constitutionnel qui existe
aujourd'hui et effectivement il faut
questionner cette cette jurisprudence
alors je l'ai évoqué tout à l'heure
cette jurisprudence nous estimons
effectivement qu'elle ne va pas assez
loin pas assez loin dans le sens où elle
a toujours le Conseil cons a toujours eu
à se prononcer sur la constitutionnalité
des textes relatifs à l'avortement mais
jamais il reconnu comme une liberté et
cela fait peser des incertitudes au cas
où un jour le Conseil constitutionnel
aura à se prononcer sur un texte qui
reviendrait en arrière et c'est là où il
fautectivement apporter et bien des
réponses au niveau constitutionnel et là
aussi en reprenant l'exigence du conseil
je pense du Conseil d'État que vous avez
été plusieurs mais notamment vous
àointer sur une rédaction qui ne
présente aucune ambiguïé ou aucune
ambivalence donc une rédaction claire et
pour ne pas être trop long parce que
beaucoup de choses ont été dites par nos
différents nos différents collègues
peut-être un dernier sur lequel je tiens
deux derniers auquels je tiens à
insister Marie Noël baptistel ce que
vous évoqueiez sur ce que vous avez
évoqué l'importance du mot garantie oui
et je vous a l'air tout et tous chers
collègues parce que nous avions été un
certain nombre à dire qu'au fond nous
pourrions reprendre le texte tel quel du
Sénat je pense qu'à partir du moment où
dans le projet de loi à partir des
travaux qui ont été menés par le
gouvernement et au regard de l'Ave du
Conseil d'État à partir du moment où il
y a l'introduction du mot garantie qui
dans les auditions on l'a bien vu en
fait était le débat clé nous ne pouvons
pas revenir en arrière je vous le dis si
le mot garantie effectivement est retiré
ça créera une ambivalence ou une
ambiguïé sur ce que nous cherchons
exactement à faire et donc il faudra et
bien tenir on va dire et apporter c'est
ce qui ressortait effectivement de votre
interpellation dernier mot chers
collègue rég effec effement
constitutionnalisé ce n'est pas banalisé
c'est sanctuirisé et c'est peut-être ce
qui doit guider nos travaux donc voilà
pour les premiers mots suite à vos
différentes interventions il reste trois
interventions on commence par Raquel
garido c'est 2 minutes
d
président le gardessau monsieur le
Président Monsieur le gardau Rapporteur
chers
collègues c'est un moment solennel car
c'est rare dans la vie d'un député en
tout cas dans la mienne mais je crois
aussi dans la vôtre d'exercer non pas le
pouvoir législatif ordinaire mais le
pouvoir législatif constituant c'est une
démarche qui est en fait tout autre que
ce que l'on fait d'habitude et elle elle
cette démarche selon moi ne consiste pas
tant à faire vivre les les grandes
oppositions dans la société mais au
contraire puisqu'il s'agit de la norme
suprême de de de dénoncer très
clairement l'état des grandes majorit
dans la société c'est-à-dire la façon
dont les Français dans leur grande
majorité se perçoivent perçoivent leur
grandes droit leur grande liberté et je
voudrais répondre à un argument qui a
été donné par celles et ceux qui
contestent l'utilité de
constitutionnaliser le droit ou la
liberté de recourir à l'IVG notamment
j'ai entendu ce matin le tête de liste
aux Européennes de LR François Xavier
bami qui dit que c'est inutile j'ai
entendu le RN aujourd'hui en commission
des lois et un des arguments qu'il dit
c'est
ça ne sert à rien vu que tout le monde
est d'accord l'IVG tout le monde est
finalement d'accord pour le droit à
recourir donc ben il y a pas de risque
et bien la question que je pose dans ce
cas si tout le monde est d'accord c'est
pourquoi ça ne figure pas dans la
constitution et la question qu'on doit
se poser nous comme pouvoir législatif
constituant c'est comment se fait-il
qu'il y a cette béance sur un droit qui
est absolument fondamental pour les
femmes et qui qui en réalité tel que ça
a pu être à demimot reconnu par le
Conseil constitutionnel sans lequel il
ne peut pas fondamentalement y avoir
d'égalité de droit entre les femmes et
les hommes lorsque le Conseil
constitutionnel a a validé le droit à
recourir à l'IVG comme conforme à la
Constitution c'était en le fondant sur
le préambule de 46 son aligné à 3 et
l'idée d'égalité entre les hommes et les
femmes et donc précisément pour être
dans cette égalité il nous faut pouvoir
maîtriser notre procréation alors je
termine en disant que je considère qu'il
va nous falloir débattre notamment de
l'emplacement non pas pour mettre en
cause le processus mais pour enrichir ce
moment constituant Monsieur Xavier
Bruton oui merci monsieur le président
monsieur le garde des saous mes chers
collègues oui nous aurons l'occasion
demain en examinant les les amendements
que nous avons pu déposer de de de
préciser un petit peu la la la rédaction
et et ses impacts mais je voudrais quand
même tout de suite aller à l'encontre
d'une affirmation qui consiste à dire la
France va être le premier pays euh à
inscrire les VG dans la Constitution
entendez monsieur le garde des saau dire
que ça ça aurait de la gueule ou ça
aurait de l'allure vous avez rectifié
tout à fait et en disant que la France
des Lumières peut éclairer le monde
entier il y a déjà un pays qui a éclairé
qui a éclairé le monde entier c'est la
youoslavie en 1974 l'article 191 de la
Constitution yougoslave avait inscrit le
droit à l'IVG en même temps d'ailleurs
il prévoyait que le président Tito
allait devenir président à vie donc il y
avait eu effectivement déjà dans la
youoslavie socialiste cette éclairage
universel que vous revendiquez c'est
simplement pour vous inciter à un peu de
modestie avant l'examen de ce texte et
qu'on entende plus effectivement que la
France va être le premier pays à
inscrire le droit à l'vgé dans la
Constitution c'était déjà fait il y a
maintenant 50 ans puisque c'est en 1974
avec la Yugoslavie chacun a les
références qu'il
peut mari
Caram alors merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le rapporteur et Monsieur le
Ministre trois hommes effectivement qui
porte quelque part aujourd'hui une
volonté parlementaire puisque c'est la
volonté parlementaire vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure de passer par par cette
évolution et et donc en tant que femme
et parlementaire je suis vraiment ravi
de de d'arriver là aujourd'hui à cet
objectif qui était recherché depuis très
longtemps même si comme ça a été bien
dit par ma collègue Noël wattist Mar no
malel et puis des autres collègues il y
a des choses qui voilà qui nous ont posé
questions mais qu'on voulait en tout cas
volonté de soutenir cette démarche elle
était supérieure je voulais juste
profiter de cette de ce moment monsieur
le ministre pour peut-être revenir un
petit peu sur le sujet effectivement
l'inscription à la constitu dans la
Constitution évidemment on est donc
favorable parce qu'il est plus difficile
quand même de de changer celle-ci et de
l'interpréter à la suite dans un sens
défavorable à un tel droit mais je pense
aussi qu'il est utile de rappeler que
les pouvoirs publics et à tous les
niveaux doivent accorder aussi une
priorité dans d'autres éléments priorité
élevé à la protection de la santé des
droits sexuels des repr et reproductif
des femmes soutenir les politiques
actives je dirais d'accès effectif à la
contraception et garantir l'exercice
réel du droit des femmes à l'accès à
l'IVG ça veut dire que certes il faut
inscrire les droits dans la Constitution
nous sommes pour mais ça ne suffira pas
il faudra aussi travailler sur la
difficulté d'accès justement à des
praticiens l'absence de centres
spécialisé l'éloignement également des
disparités régionales qui perdurent y
compris dans notre pays on le sait donc
que des obstacles culturelle pratique
économique entrave l'accès à la santé
reproductive et au droits d'IVG de donc
effectivement oui il il faut reconnaître
c'est reconnu reconnaître la liberté il
faut la garantir et ça a été rappelé
tout à l'heure par le rapporteur qu'on
garantit la liberté mais quelle
politique et quelle mesure vous pouvez
aussi au niveau du gouvernement au
niveau du ministère et
interministériel mettre en place à côté
de cette constitutionnalisation de l'IVG
pour aller plus loin
merci et enfin monsieur F goselin merci
monsieur le Président quelques quelques
mots à mon tour pour replacer dans le
dans le contexte le contexte celui qui a
été un peu politique c'est celui des
arrêts de l'arrêt de la Cour suprême des
États-Unis et on fait une transposition
un peu rapide un peu facile moi je
rappelle que le système juridique
américain celui de la Cour suprême n'a
rien à voir avec le nôtre et comparaison
n'est pas raison donc quatre fois et la
dernière fois c'était en 2016 c'est pas
en en 75 le Conseil constitutionnel
s'est prononcé sur la
constitutionnalité de l'IVG en France et
je crois que sur le plan constitutionnel
en réalité il n'y a pas de risque
d'atteinte même avec un changement de
majorité parce que je crois
qu'aujourd'hui ce droit à l'avortement
il fait partie du bloc d'une certaine
façon de constitutionnalité avec un
certain nombre d'autres de grands
principes dans la continuité de la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel de
71 qui était l'acte l'acte fondateur
quand on a dit ça on y voit finalement
plus un débat politique que juridique on
rappellera aussi la petite guégerre de
PPL entre la présidente Panau et la
présidente berger qui ont dégainé à
quelques heures d'intervalle pour
essayer de préempter le sujet c'est bon
aussi de l'avoir en tête sans naïveté il
y a derrière tout ça une occasion de
réunir quelques éléments de gauche pour
oublier que il y a des fissures ou des
fractures qui sont arrivés un peu avant
Noël notamment bref quand on a dit ça
quand on a dit ça non non mais les l'air
vont bien en ce moment rassurez-vous
tout va bien mais écoutez que chacun
s'occupe de ses têtes de liste aux
Européennes et on en reparlera chers
amis chers collègues bref ministre
chacun il trouvera son son bonheur à pas
douter et et plus longuement que mes 2
minutes bref nous avons nous vous l'avez
compris un certain nombre de questions
de fond qu'il est important d'aborder ça
c'est l'objet des amendements que dont
nous débatttrons demain qui ne se
veulent absolument pas de l'obstruction
mais des réponses à des questions
précises une révision de la Constitution
ce n'est pas rien c'est la voix de
l'article 34 qui est utilisé mais
quelles sont ces garanties que sont ces
droits et libertés liberté en
l'occurrence tout ça nous le verrons
demain et ça sera l'objet de nos
amendements et donc véritablement enfin
Madame
cécilemea très rapidement pour dire
quand même que c'est un combat que nous
menons depuis quand même quelques années
puisque Marie Noë btistel a parlé de
2018 2019 des amendements que nous
avions déposés nous avons également
déposé une proposition de loi à ce sujet
en ancrant ce cette protection à
l'article 1er de la Constitution mais
nous acceptons totalement les avancées
qui ont été faites parce que finalement
c'est le compromis qui doit qui doit
aboutir dans la loi
fondamentale moi ma première remarque
c'est que je ne comprend pas qu'on
puisse s'opposer à la création d'un
droit on vous oblige pas à aller à l'IVG
on vous demande simplement de permettre
aux personnes qui en ont
exprimer la volonté de pouvoir le faire
donc je crois que que la création d'un
droit c'est
toujours un moment important et joyeux
finalement dans notre dans notre le
législatif ma deuxème ma deuxème
remarque c'est que effectivement cette
inscription si elle arrive dans la
Constitution et c'est une grande
victoire collective elle engage aussi
elle nous engage nous législateur mais
elle engage aussi le gouvernement sur la
mise en œuvre les conditions dans
lesquelles se
déroulera C cet IVG et je voulais
simplement à ce sujet parler de la
clause de conscience moi je
suis d'accord avec la clause de
conscience que peut opposer un médecin
qui ne veut pas effectuer cet acte mais
il y a dans la clause de conscience
l'obligation pour ce même médecin de
diriger vers un autre médecin en
capacité de le faire et il faut bien
admettre que ce dispositif là il est
jamais mis en place donc nous pourrons
euh à ce sujet rappeler les les
exigences et les responsabilités de
chacun ça me paraît tout à fait
essentiel et puis je rejoins le
rapporteur et je le remercie pour
l'excellence de son de son de son propos
le terme garantir est indispensable
nous avions déjà bataillé sur le
garantir ou favoriser en matière
d'environnement et je vois que là on
bataille sur le terme garantir et nous
serons à vos côté sur ce
sujet pourquoi ça se passe pas comme ça
pourquoi ça se passe pas comme ça dans
l'hémicycle mais c'est pas moi qui pose
la question au député c'est les députés
qui POS les
question ah oui mais écoutez si vous me
rappelez de mauvais souvenir alors parce
que c'est pas moi qui préside monsieur
le
rapporteur vous êtesver Mo je su de
retrouverex je souis réagir quand même à
certains points qui là aussi vont nous
occuper demain mais comme on enenchaîne
pas tout de suite sur les amendements je
pense qu'il est important d'y apporter
quand même tout de suite une réponse je
pense d'abord à à l'intervention de
notre collègue Raquel garid que je salue
d'avoord et remercie d'avoir suivi
l'ensemble des auditions et donc
effectivement il y a ce sujet de
l'emplacement qui est central et demain
nous aurons une série d'amendements qui
nous permettront je pense d'expliquer
effectivement l'opportunité et la
pertinence de l'article 34 alors on l'a
évoqué l'article
66-2 renvoie à l'autorité judiciaire et
au fond crée une ambiguïé par rapport à
la liberté qu'on veut créer il y avait
l'article 1 mais qui au fond renvoie à
des grands principes et pas à une
rédaction assez poussée et donc cet
emplacement qui a été au passage trouvé
par Philippe B je pense se défend au
regard du fait que dans notre
Constitution nous n'avons pas d'article
liminire qui liste toutes les libertés
et l'article 34 est d'une certaine
manière devenu un peu un peu ce
ce ce ce
réceptacle monsieur breton qui alors je
voulais quand même
répondre qui qui faisit un retour un peu
dans le passé sur la youoslavie au
passage l'ensemble des pays aujourd'hui
qui composent l'ancienne youoslavie ne
reconnaissent pas ne reconnaissent plus
cette cette liberté dans leur dans leur
constitution par ailleurs je pense qu'il
faut regarder la réalité aujourd'hui il
y a 10 ans ou 15 ans nous n'auurions pas
parlé effectivement de
constitutionnalisation c'est un fait et
les attaques se sont multiplié au cours
des 10 15 dernières années envers les
droits des femmes et tout
particulièrement envers ce droit qui
représente effectivement la liberté de
disposer de son corps pilier je pense de
la reconnaissance de l'égalité et
aujourd'hui il y a des pays qui dans
leur constitution ont le la notion
d'avortement c'est pour l'interdire il y
a trois pays à travers le monde c'est
pour l'interdire par ailleurs l'arops
pour répondre à notre collègue
goselin ce n'est pas de l'aredops dont
tout découle par contre c'est vrai que
l'aredops a été un déclencheur un
électrochoc pour nous parce que nous
pouvions penser en France que nous
étions protégés de ces attaques jamais
nous n'aurions imaginé qu'un tel arrêt
tomberait aux États-Unis et
effectivement ça a déclenché un
électrochoc parmi un grand nombre de
défenseurs de défenseuses des droits des
femmes qui se sont dit oui ça peut nous
arriver aujourd'hui en France par
ailleurs il est important je pense
aujourd'hui après cet arréops qui a
envoyé un effet négatif partout à
travers le monde et dans la foulée de
l'aréops et bien ça a libéré les paroles
ça a notamment libéré les paroles de
celles et ceux qui attaquent les droits
des femmes et donc c'est pour cela qu'il
est peut-être important et bien de
contrebalancer et c'est peut-être notre
responsabilité effectivement à nous
Français de contrebalancer avec un
message particulier
positif pour et bien l'ensemble de
celles et ceux qui se battent pour ces
droits à travers à travers le
monde bien ben écoutez je vous remercie
on se retrouve demain matin à 9h d'abord
pour l'audition de Madame Marie lordenis
pour sa reconduction à la tête de lail
et ensuite pour l'examen du projet de
loi constitutionnel pour lequel nous
venons d'entendre le garde des saut
merci